she's here isn't she
hi Ron it's really good to see you Ron
you've aged horribly you son-of-a-bitch
and didn't oh my god
what is your problem I did okay is that
what you want to eat we're fine we're
fine
Ronen doesn't want to break up with me
what Ron wants to do is leave here right
now go to the sleaziest motel in town
and wrap himself around me like a coiled
snake no he doesn't I'm pretty sure he
does hmm hello Tammy oh hello Ron I
didn't see you come in I was just
checking myself for scoliosis and
straight as an arrow just like somebody
else I know
jerky call off the dogs you and I both
know that in my entire adult life I have
never checked a book out of the library
oh she's amazing oh I admit there was a
time when that sort of behavior would
have driven me wild but I'm in a healthy
relationship now tame a relationship
with him a lovely intelligent
self-possessed pediatric surgeon named
Wendy sounds like a real [ __ ] it's been
like this for an hour
Leslie congratulate us Ron's got one
just like it on his penis oh yeah what
the hell happened to you
[Music]
you may now kiss the bride a new library
card read the name Tammy Swanson Swanson
well you're bout ready to go my love
wait
run stop Tom Jerry what the hell don't
do it
she doesn't love you you don't know what
you're talking about what are you doing
here
yes I do okay what asked her to be my
date she tackled for a full minute and
said and I quote anything to make Ron
miserable it's not real man she's just
messing with you he's lying Ron stay out
of this gland it's Tom
and I'm not lying I'm not gonna let you
destroy Ron you're just gonna have you
almost had me again but seeing you pick
on this pathetic defenseless little man
hey reminded me what kind of a monster
you are you're a joke you're not even a
man anymore
oh and by the way last night I faked
four out of the seven so did I let's go
son
she's here who's here my ex-wife Tammy -
I can smell the sulfur coming off her
cloven hooves good nose Ron Tammy
Swanson is here she'll be my next
witness Tammy - is your killer witness
please you're gonna have to do better
actually she is a terrifying sociopath
who could say or do anything a pretty
good killer witness miss Watson do you
as you claimed have evidence linking
Leslie Knope and Ben Wyatt to law
breaking absolutely
I have several photographs that will
definitively prove that remind you that
you are under oath and if you lie I will
fire you and have you prosecuted nothing
they won't definitively prove don't
think well you cut me off I don't have
any evidence Oh Chris so silly okay bye
guys Leslie have fun with this trial
yeah this could end up being the best
night in Ron Swanson's life I am so so
happy for him hello you gorgeous
craftsman Wow look at this room so much
wood ready to be worked me Quinn sidin
gosh I never dreamed you'd be here Tammy
this is Diane Diane this is a piece of
human garbage named Tammy who is also my
ex-wife oh my gosh what a co-inky-dink
Hey look we're sitting at the same table
Tammy this table is reserved a guy
traded me a seat for a peek in a squeeze
that's my boob and my butt respectively
remember that Ron this award is the only
one I'd ever give a damn about I made my
first chair when I was five but the
quality of the wood was wanting so when
I turned nine I used my factory wages to
purchase some beautiful local walnut
thank you for this this all good night
good there it is
[Applause]
big gross Leslie where's one it's too
late Tammy Ron's gone we'll never get
him back my bet that relationship is
weak all I have to do is find Ron within
the next few hours and he's toast Hey
game over Tammy turned on right now what
is wrong with y'all yeah tell me you're
not feeling this you're crazy
[Music]
I mean I'd do anything for Ron even
spend a whole night fighting his crazy
ex-wife I think I'm safe she's gotta be
tired by now I've given this a lot of
thought we should break up
what's the matter little boy the bad
people get to you they just made me
realize how unhealthy this is literally
all the steak and whiskey I have to wear
a diaper Oh baby we drilled you on this
Cham Baby Talk what do you do I'm not a
baby I'm a big boy yeah okay well that
wasn't terrible
don't listen to Leslie she's trying to
manipulate you all she cares about is
herself and I can prove it
how's this Leslie you leave us alone and
we swing the vote to you help you get
your park
no nice try stay strong Jeremy it's over
Tammy tell you what it's been long
enough what do you say we consummate our
relationship
tonight huh let's do it oh and the last
card is played
what are you doing Shh
Ron I need that crotch blinder no you
don't just end it with my boobs
no look downstairs no there's a prize
inside for you it's over Tammy what to
hell with you woman
goodbye GRU well done Jeremy
brings out the cross blinder was inside
you all along
you